how's the economy doing dude is it a
troll tactic it's pretty okay so here's
an important thing about the economy and
okay so everybody just when they they
talk about a surplus they talk about a
surplus okay in in california because
all these companies in silicon valley
are going public so there's a 95 billion
dollar
tax
like um
uh
that goes 95 billion dollars in taxes
are going to the state because of
silicon valley
no one has been more [ __ ] um hostile
to big tech and to san francisco that
created all that wealth than the newsome
administration and all of the [ __ ]
far left people in sacramento so guess
what all of tech did they left yes so
you're huge all the money you made off
those all all those companies airbnb all
those companies that started in
california in that 21 mile radius some
of the most innovative people on the
planet uber [ __ ] airbnb you name it
oh i don't know google you ever heard of
google nope yeah
all these companies that changed the
facebook
all these companies that changed the
world okay that we can just keep going
everything you use that all your tech
started in a time it was just a good old
boys network it was just a bunch of
dudes nerdy dudes who were sitting there
in a room and they they all wanted to
make money and they changed the [ __ ]
world because there was an incentive to
make money and everybody was like if i
have a good idea i'll make a billion
dollars and they all [ __ ] did now
they all went public this year remember
though
you got guys like elon musk who are up
there paypal all that [ __ ] was all that
ecosystem they all worked competing
against each other sharing ideas it was
one of the most incredible times bill
gates microsoft even though that was in
washington but it was all within that
ecosystem it all started in [ __ ] it
all started in san francisco silicon
valley and so there was there hasn't
been that kind of a hotbed of innovation
that changed the world in so long yes it
was all white it was all straight males
i know they're all terrible i don't care
who it is yeah who gives a [ __ ] i don't
care who it is the best idea it's just
the best ideas it was just happened to
have been could be transgender it
doesn't matter i don't give a [ __ ] it
was just it just happened to have been a
group of people that changed the [ __ ]
world's smartest [ __ ] and gave so much
tax revenue to california right they've
all left and they all have because you
have a congresswoman in [ __ ]
california who says [ __ ] elon musk
that's what she said she's she's in
congress she goes [ __ ] elon musk so elon
musk goes really you guys just want to
make my life impossible i'm going to
leave in san francisco and this was just
an article written by a liberal reporter
who is a who is a lesbian woman okay and
she she goes
these these far progressive
anti-business people have killed one of
the greatest [ __ ] cities in america
and it's called san francisco and you
think it's a dead [ __ ] town anything
both touches turns to [ __ ] so one thing
trump got right so don't you know it's
not about we all we're all for equality
we're all for not being prejudiced all
that [ __ ] but you don't know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about yeah how's
that going for you guys unbelievable man
and this one do you want to take the
better now with newsome uh because you
seem pretty high the point ten g point
is vote for newsome guys